i've made a lot of hogwarts legacy
videos but never one quite like this
guys we have so much to talk about here
but i'm not gonna bury the lead i'll
just cut right to the chase i've been
contacted by multiple people with behind
the scenes gameplay details regarding
hogwarts legacy first take all of this
with a grain of salt i'm going to
explain why in this video that i think
the information is legit for those of
you who have followed the channel for a
while you know how skeptical i always am
when rumors and leaks like this pop up i
don't even cover all of them simply
because there are so many for the new
folks i'm not a leaker as i say in many
of my videos i'm just a dad who loves
games and the stories they tell in this
case i'm just a hogwarts legacy fan
making videos on the internet and
reporting on something i've been told
one i've been told the developers were
heavily inspired by the level design of
ghost of tsushima the last of us part 2
and the legend of zelda breath of the
wild two i'm hearing that enemy camps
will be a core part of gameplay with
combat stealth and exploration all
playing a role three the game will also
include dungeons in addition to the
enemy camps and there was an entire team
dedicated to designing these four there
are multiple regions included in the
open world
5. relationships are in the game and
have storylines designed to emotionally
engage players 6. multiple towns are
included and feature npcs with unique
behaviors and conversations to feel like
a living breathing town and seven day
and night cycles are in the game and
because i know you're wondering no there
was not a mention of seasons but that
doesn't mean they aren't in the game
okay wow boy do we have a lot to talk
about to be totally honest this isn't
the first time i've been contacted
regarding supposed behind the scenes
details usually it's pretty easy to tell
that it's completely fake just someone
looking for attention or trying to trick
me into making a video on something fake
who knows i don't know why they do it
why is this one different first of all
some of the things i just listed were
sent to me by two different people
basically within two days of one another
also one of them actually included photo
evidence which unfortunately i can't
share here but i do believe that these
photos are legitimate and i believe this
source does have information on the game
or source is i should say now two
additional things here i personally
believe this information that i've
shared is accurate secondly though i
also believe any of it could change at
any point in game development for those
of you who follow games you know there
are sometimes things that get cut that
many people have worked on for months
and months and months at the same time
though i also have to say several of
those points i listed are more
high-level game design ideas so for them
to be cut it would be pretty surprising
so those are all of the caveats now
let's actually talk about the
information i just shared and what it
could mean because whoa boy almost
everything there gets me super super
excited so first design inspiration from
ghost of tsushima the last of us part 2
and the legend of zelda breath of the
wild are you kidding me music to my ears
sign me up as well as the bit about
enemy camps i mean those three games
right there i think of those games so
highly i know people didn't love the
last was part two story but remember
we're talking about level design here
and the gameplay in the last of us part
two was incredible then zelda breath of
the wild just how open that world was
and how you could just go anywhere and
do anything you wanted to do and tackle
the different camps in so many different
ways same thing with ghost of tsushima
that game was just lauded and lauded
with praise for how they handled the
open world if hogwarts legacy comes even
close you guys to touching what these
games did on that level then this game
is going to be insane i also think those
two points right there really paint a
picture in my head for a much bigger
game than what i had been imagining i
don't know maybe it's just a case of me
trying to keep my expectations in check
but when they said open world i don't
know that i ever really took them truly
at their word and open world i was
thinking okay we're just gonna have a
super wide open hogwarts with all sorts
of stuff to do in the castle and then
we'll have these kind of smaller areas
that we can sort of dip out to from time
to time but it's not gonna be this
sprawling landscape now though i'm
starting to think guys is the dream a
reality is what we have been hoping for
all along actually going to happen i
mean look at this wallpaper for breath
of the wild and then compare it to this
hogwarts legacy shot here it's the same
one i used in the thumbnail of this
video how have we missed this guys this
is like such a clear
parallel right here i mean it's like
they were trying to tell us all along
look here's the game that we're looking
to to inspire us those covers right
there i guess we don't really know if
it's the hogwarts legacy cover just yet
but let's just say it is if those are
the two covers right there i mean look
at the similarities is that what they
were trying to get at all along then the
next bit about dungeons like are you
kidding me this part was a little bit
more vague it wasn't as clear as the
enemy encampments that we talked about
but if it's what i'm thinking you know
i'm thinking a zelda style dungeon like
you have this area where you sort of
make your way through a series of
smaller areas and then you come to a
large area that's going to require you
to who knows solve some sort of puzzle
encounter some enemies maybe learn a new
spell to be clear that's just me sort of
guessing and spitballing right there but
i want to be clear there was a whole
separate design team again from what
i've been told a separate design team
that was specifically devoted to
dungeons same thing for the enemy camp
so it's clear there are two separate
things there at least to me it seems
that way and just the way i kind of
imagine it in my head is that these
enemy camps are things that we're gonna
encounter across the open world and then
the dungeons would actually be something
larger
than just sort of these random hotspots
on the map all right the next point
multiple regions in the open world so
what's interesting about this one is i
can't put an exact number on it but i
know that it is at least three
most likely more in terms of regions but
again this just goes back to sort of my
expectation being much smaller than what
it sounds like the game is actually
working toward here i mean multiple
regions like where all are we gonna be
able to go in this game you guys let's
just stop and think here they've already
confirmed hogwarts of course that's the
big one they've already confirmed
hogsmeade they've confirmed the
forbidden forest we do see azkaban in
the trailer my mind is just running like
crazy now we're gonna go to godric's
hollow are we gonna go to the ministry
of magic are we gonna go to some sort of
special quidditch stadium i mean i know
help me rein it in guys next a bit about
relationships and story lines this is
also something that makes total sense
with what avalanche has told us from the
beginning particularly the bit about
choosing companions that much is
confirmed already by avalanche we know
that we will be able to choose
companions throughout the game but this
to me actually hints at the possibility
of there being separate storylines
depending on which companions we choose
which is something i have definitely
wanted in the game we've talked about it
here on the channel before then another
one that speaks to the scythe and scope
this idea of multiple towns that is
specifically the word that was used here
towns plural along with npcs who have
unique behaviors and conversations so
that last bit isn't too surprising
considering most open world games have
really been making an effort to improve
this aspect of having different areas
feel unique and different but again i'm
just so taken aback by this scope here i
mean multiple towns other than hogsmeade
like where all are we going to be
traveling in this game you guys this
just sounds so incredibly insane and i
mean that in the best way possible think
about all the different possibilities
for fast travel now we see hippogrips
flying in the trailer i mean that very
well could be a shot of us flying to a
completely different region a completely
different town and then we have the
piece about day and night cycles i
personally think seasons will be in the
game too even though this wasn't part of
anything i heard and i also don't think
day night cycles is too big of a
surprise it's certainly something people
have wanted though in the old harry
potter games they had it where you
actually had to advance to the next day
but this sounds like it will be more
like that zelda ocarina of time zelda
breath of the wild style where things
are always kind of changing around you
as i said in the beginning guys take it
with a grain of salt if you haven't
already seen we did find out that there
is going to be an official hogwarts
legacy art book possibly launching in
september check out that video on the
right side of your screen right now as
always thank you all so much for
watching i'll talk to you again soon